fire-based cloud messaging allows you to
send push notifications throughout
multiple devices even after naps been
closed it does this on the web by
registering a service worker that
listens for messages from firebase in
the background as you can see here we've
completely closed our angular app in the
browser but we still get this push
notification on our operating system
directly from firebase many apps do this
to notify their users of important
information such as slack which will
notify users when they have a new
mention on our channel let's get started
by building this worker into our angular
app create a new file in the source
directory called Cloud messaging SW jas
then inside that file will import the
firebase SDK and initialize it with only
the messaging sender ID then we set a
variable with the firebase
messaging library that's actually all we
need to do to set up the background
worker everything else will happen
automatically however to ensure
compatibility with modern browsers we
need to add a manifest.json file inside
this file we include the GCM sender ID
which is the same for all applications
so keep it the same as it appears in
this video and then you'll want to link
the manifest in the head of your
index.html file to ensure these two
newly created files get included when we
build the app we want to add them to the
angular CLI dot JSON file with the
initial setup down we can start building
the service we're going to need both the
angular fired database and angular fire
auth modules as well as the firebase SDK
we're going to keep track with the most
recent message with a behavior subject
which is just an observable that we can
push new data to so the way cloud
messaging works is the browser will
first ask the user for permission for an
app to send them cloud messages and then
firebase will give us a token once that
permission has been granted what we need
to do is save that token with the user's
auth ID on the firebase database so we
can use it on the backend when we start
sending messages with firebase cloud
functions to do that we will subscribe
to the angular fire off state taking
only one just to prevent a long-running
subscription then we'll save the auth ID
is the key with the token is the value
in a collection called FCM
tokens in the database the token will
change any time the user clears their
browser cache so it's important to
update this token periodically in this
example we're going to update the token
every time this get permission function
runs this will happen whenever the
browser asks the user for permission to
send them notifications the request
permission function will trigger that
pop-up that the user has to confirm and
then from there we can get the token and
update the token in the database the
last thing we need to do is listen for
new messages and then we'll update that
behavior subject whenever a new message
is received we do this by calling on
message which will return the message
from firebase and then we can call next
on our behavior subject and pass a phat
value so now we can use these functions
in the app component or any other
component that you want to set up
messaging with when the user is actively
using the app we want to show the
notification inside the app itself we
don't want it to come from some external
source which would be distracting so to
do that we inject the messaging service
and first get permission and then we set
up the receive message function and then
set a variable on the component to that
behavior subject again a behavior
subject is just in observable so we can
unwrap it in the template with the async
pipe so here we're handling the
notification in angular and it should
look something like this notice the
message appears directly in our angular
app and not coming from the external
browser or operating system if the app
were closed at the time the semester's
was sent the service worker would take
over and send the message to the
external browser or operating system now
that we know how to receive messages we
need a way to send them which I'm going
to do with a firebase cloud function if
you don't want to deploy cloud function
check out the link in the description
where I provide a curl command to send
push messages over HTTP but in most
cases you're going to be sending push
notifications when something happens in
your database so it's a perfect fit for
firebase cloud functions in this example
we're going to create a function called
FCM send and it's going to run during
the on create trigger in the database so
anytime new data is added to the
messages for a given user this function
will run so we'll define a variable
called pelo
and that's the actual message that's
going to be seen by the user from there
we'll tap into the admin database and
get the token for that user so we'll
chain together a couple promises and
then once we have the actual token we
can send that to the firebase messaging
library we call send to device and send
it the token as well as that payload or
the message this is what will actually
trigger the message to be sent to that
device and that's pretty much it
pretty simple cloud function go ahead
and deploy the function and you should
be ready to start sending messages to
your users as you can see here we update
some data on the messages node and the
user is automatically updated with that
push notification if this video helped
you please like and subscribe and if
you're serious about angular and
firebase consider becoming a pro member
at angular firebase com we'll get a free
copy of my book the angular firebase
survival guide thanks for watching and
I'll talk to you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]